we live in a beautiful world surrounded
by genius sharkskin is antimicrobial and
reduces drag lotus leaf plants have
self-cleaning surfaces peacock feathers
create color without pigment gecko foot
pads create adhesion without adhesives
I've always been fascinated by the
natural world number one I see the
inherent beauty but secondly on a deeper
level I look and I see possible solution
sets to design challenges I'm Maria
O'Farrell and I'm a biomimicry
professional what that means is it's my
job to go into companies and help them
solve design challenges using three
point eight billion years of research
and development from the natural world
my name is Kevin back and I work at
Lenovo Engineering is ultimately all
about iteration you rarely get anything
right
the first time you build it and you test
it and you figure out what's wrong with
it
and then you improve it and you do that
again and again and again and again but
nature has been doing that for billions
of years so sometimes it helps to sort
of skip ahead in the process and see
what solution nature came up with
that's what biomimicry is all about
taking the best of nature and seeing if
we can somehow adapt that to solve a
technology problem so here's a good
example of how this works we've got a
thermal and cooling engineer was faced
with a reasonably large challenge of
creating a new type of fan to go into a
new all-in-one desktop by necessity it
has to be really really thin but also be
really really quiet so this engineer
took his son to the aquarium on a
Saturday and there was a dolphin show
so he's sitting there watching the
dolphin show and he notices that come
out of the water they go back into the
water it's very clean exit very clean
entry because of the shape of their body
dolphins of all a design strategy so
that they can move through the water
quickly with the least amount of noise
to capture their prey we had this kind
of aha moment that said hmm if they're
that efficient in water I wonder if that
structure might also work for a fan in
air water has 500 times the frictional
drag that air does so if you found
something that can do it in water it
stands to reason that you've found a
pretty good design for the air
so he goes back and sort of mocks up
this design at his CAD program didn't
work very well at all the 1st 2nd 3rd
4th 5th time but he finally got to
something that actually works really
really well there's a fan blade and on
the ends of the tips of the blades as a
little structure that looks kind of like
a dolphins body that are very efficient
at moving air very very quiet
there are a number of other examples of
biomimicry and Lenovo products as well
stands inspired by the shape of an
orchid stem fans inspired by the shape
of an owl's wing cooling vents inspired
by the honeycomb structure of a beehive
each of these designs have all in some
way been made better by biomimicry we
are natural beings we're animals and I
think a lot of the problems that we face
are tied indelibly to the fact that we
have divorced ourselves from nature but
the good news is again as a young
species that we have a lot of mentors
and evolutionary elders and a life's
operating manual that we can consult all
of the solutions we seek out or right in
front of us were surrounded by genius
you